Miley Cyrus and Kaitlyn Carter are
taking their hot girls summer back to
the States
I'm like the luckiest ever the two were
spotted together in LA for the first
time since photos surfaced over the
weekend of them kissing in Lake Como the
gals were cruising in a Tesla Miley in
the driver's seat with penguin in the
passenger never a bad time to try though
Miley has yet to speak out on her split
from Liam Hemsworth publicly her older
sister Brandi who was also on the girls
trip to Italy made sure to let us know
she's got her sister's back on a recent
episode of her and Wells Adams podcast
Brandi told Wells that she and her
sister haven't spoken much on the
subject quote it's not my business to
talk about and it's nothing anything of
mine to tell adding I'm here for her
obviously and I've been spending a lot
of time with her when she's ready to
talk about it or whatever then she will
as for the rest of the Cyrus family a
source told ET earlier this week quote
Miley's parents have been supportive
they just want her to be happy
[Music]
[Applause]